- Most people have a stressful life.
And if you look at stress,
stress happens as a result
of things not fitting your pictures.
Perfection is the lowest standard.
And the reason it's the lowest standard
is because it's unattainable.
Failure?
Failure is not taking your step.
Failure is not picking up the bat
and swinging it at life.
Failure is getting to the end of this game
and regretting what we didn't do.
I'm a born entrepreneur.
I've built several dozen companies,
half of which before the age of 30.
I'm a best-selling author, philosopher
and explorer of consciousness.
My name is Peter Sage,
and these are my 10 rules for success.
(exploding swoosh)
(powerful music)
Probably the most important
way to encourage yourself
to work harder is to increase your why.
You see, the psychological fact
that people do things for reasons,
now, they may not be your reasons,
and they may not be my reasons,
but everybody does things for reasons.
And so what you do when
you're working hard
or you're working on a project,
you're doing it because
there's a reason for it.
Now if your motivation is low,
it's because your reason, the
reason that you're doing it
doesn't resonate at a high level.
So how do you increase your why?
Well, one the ways that I found
is by focusing on what is the outcome
of what it is that you're doing,
and how can that serve beyond you
to people that you care about
or the world at large?
People can be motivated by
themselves up to a point.
But when you start motivating yourself
because of what you can contribute,
you tap into a deeper level of motivation.
You know, it's a fact, if you
look at the New York Marathon,
The Boston Marathon, The London Marathon,
there's more people
that run those marathons
for the first time,
running for other people,
causes, charities.
And then think about
how much it would take
to motivate yourself
if you've never ran a marathon before
to go and train for one.
And getting up when you
need to do a 20K, or
a 15-mile training run and it's
cold and wet and miserable,
and you haven't eaten
properly and you're tired,
but you got to go do it anyway.
If we're doing it for ourselves,
a lot of the time we can quit.
But if we're doing it for others,
there's something that compels us.
If you've got to get up early
to go get yourself to a certain place,
and you're not feeling
motivated, it's hard.
But if you've got to get up and go,
because your boss will
fire you if you don't,
or you got to pick the
kids up from the airport,
there's a different reason.
So focus on what it is that is your why.
And checking, 6is it self-serving,
which is limiting in its power?
Or is it more ethnocentric,
whereby I'm doing it for a reason.
And find a reason to be able to contribute
with what it is that you're doing.
Over time, and especially
in personal development,
many people have put different emphasis
on different buzzwords,
things like persistence, and
desire, and determination,
words that usually have a
lot of strength behind them.
Words that really have a connotation to
being able to battle through.
And while things like desire,
persistence, determination,
et cetera, are very useful,
they're useful for when
we go through obstacles,
when we require an
immediate injection of force
to try and break through
certain levels of limitation.
In other words, if we are sitting
there as a victim of life,
and we want to be able to break
out and take charge of our
own circumstances, words
like persistence and desire,
and being able to break
through, are valuable words.
But I'd like to give you an
insight into a word that I think
is far more powerful.
And this word has been given
to us throughout the ages
by prophets, scholars, religious teachers,
spiritual masters, consistently,
since the dawn of written civilization,
and that is the word surrender.
The word surrender is
inherent into letting go
of resistance.
If you think of, for example, stress,
most people have a stressful life.
And if you look at stress,
stress happens as a result
of things not fitting your picture.
In other words, if you take
the scientific definition,
it's two objects going against each other
with opposing forces
in opposite directions.
Not like, for example,
if you take a dance,
and I'm doing Salsa dance,
and I take a lady on an outside turn,
then we're going in opposite directions.
And that's fine, you're
going with the flow.
But if she's trying to
move on an inside turn,
and I'm doing an outside
turn, you have a friction,
a resistance, and that's going
to end up in a broken wrist.
So being able to surrender at the point
has a different connotation.
So let's look into it a little more.
If we're trying to force
our way through life,
battling through,
surrender is not an option
for most people.
But if we start to look deeper
and know that the wisdom
behind the intelligence
that governs a lot of
the flow of the river of life,
let's call in the current of life,
has an innate level of intelligence
that goes beyond what we
can comprehend consciously.
How do I know that?
Very simple, cut your
finger and consciously
try to stop it from healing.
There's something smarter
than us that's at work there.
Whereas, if we were to
surrender to the wisdom
of the current of the river,
if we were to surrender
to that level of intelligence, then eh,
what generally happens is that
a solution to our problems
will present itself.
If you want to flow with
the wisdom of the current,
know that if life takes a
left turn, which it has to,
you look at any river from the air,
and regardless of the
topography, regardless
of where you are on the planet,
they all follow the
same pattern, they wind.
Just like the roads around
me in the background here,
they all wind in a different pattern.
So if you have a goal in mind,
and you've gone through persistence,
you've gone through determination,
and yet still struggling, try surrendering
to the inevitably of it happening
by flowing with the wisdom of the current.
And if you do that, and you tap into
that innate level of wisdom,
that has been passed
down through the ages,
you'll start to see surrender
as alignment with the current,
rather than resisting it.
If we understand that for
the majority of people
on the planet, money is
nothing more than a reflection
of the value that they've added,
then we start to understand
that what has to come first
is the value, not going
around chasing money.
If you chase money,
you'll chase your tail,
because you're chasing the
consequence of something
that hasn't happened yet.
Does that make sense?
So if you look at it under that context,
then how do you start a
business with no money?
Well, you don't ask yourself,
"Where do I get money?"
You ask yourself a better question.
You say, "Where is it
that I can add value?
"How can I add value?
"What is it that I can
contribute that would
"cause somebody to be
able to give me what it is
"that I want, without just
shelling out a wad of cash."
That's the easy way.
All money is an arbitrary
medium of exchange
to measure different levels of value,
that's pretty much it.
So if we don't have access to money,
then what we have to
do is come up with ways
we can add value, and therefore
we shortcut the process.
One of the patterns that
I'm noticing here, Eric,
in a lot of consistent ways
with new entrepreneurs,
is that they're covering up their lack
of ability to handle
uncertainty by doing research,
under the guise of chasing perfectionism.
- Yeah.
- Right?
That's like saying, well,
listen, I'm going to read
all the books on darts that I can read
so that my first dart is
going to be a bullseye.
- Yeah.
- That doesn't work.
Get up, stand up to
the plate, or the oche,
throw the dart, and the
first one may miss the board.
But then you adjust, you
throw the second one,
it gets a little closer,
you throw the third one,
it gets a little closer.
Eventually, you're going
to be getting bullseyes,
because you're used to throwing,
not used to reading books on darts.
- Your experience.
Your experience is getting
better on this one.
Yeah, so.
- See, if I'm trying to be perfect,
then to all you perfectionist
people out there,
listen to me.
Again, another one of my mentors,
I've spent on many years
with, Tony Robbins, right,
will tell you perfection
is the lowest standard.
And the reason it's
the the lowest standard
is because it's unattainable.
So why are you trying to be perfect?
By being perfect, you
guarantee you never will be.
- Most people try to be perfect,
try do this exactly--
- Now, most people are
afraid of being imperfect,
exactly.
- But I think this is go
to the procrastination problem.
They procrastinate or--
- Under the guise of research.
- Yeah.
- Well, I'll just do
two more focus groups,
or I'll just like do another hours surfing
to see if there's any other
ideas I can benchmark.
No, shut up, do your
research--
- That's not good, yeah.
- Limit it, get in the
game, swing the bat,
then reassess, but at
least you're in the game.
Set yourself up to win.
Now, this may sound easy, but
let me give you some insight
into brain chemistry.
Now one of my good friends, Dave Asprey,
from the Bulletproof
team, yeah, amazing man,
shared this with me, and that is that
the brain, although it's
1/50th of the body weight,
takes up 20% of the calories.
20% of the energy in your body
goes to running your brain.
Now if that energy is low, guess what?
You feel demotivated.
And a lot of the time, people
try and rely on willpower.
But willpower isn't on demand.
Willpower has cycles based
upon whether your brain
is being fed the energy it needs.
So if you are feeling down, and think,
"Ah, I was going to commit
to that, but I can't,
"I'm just not in the mood."
And you don't want to work harder,
then first things first, go
check your brain chemistry,
get yourself some fast
sugars into the diet,
get some high quality
brain fuel to be able to
perk yourself back up at
that level then go do it.
Another great way of
setting yourself up to win,
is that when you're in
the mood to do something,
prepare something for when you're going
to be doing the project.
In other words, I'll give you an example.
If you go to bed at night,
put your gym kit at the bottom of the bed
if you're going to the gym in the morning.
Research has shown, if you get out of bed,
and that gym kit is more
than 20 seconds away,
you're not likely to make it
if you're not in the mood.
But if your gym kit is
at the foot of the bed,
and you get out and the first
thing you do is put it on,
you're ahead of the game.
Set yourself up to win.
So when I'm in the mood
and I am energized,
my brain chemistry's
high, and I'm associated
to what I'm doing,
do something in that moment to take action
towards setting yourself
up for when you know
predictably that cycle's going to dip.
'Cause you can't be in
uptime all the while.
That's a superhuman myth.
Well, here's the tip.
It's not looking for more sales,
it's not getting up
earlier and making calls.
It's not knocking on doors.
The fastest way to make money
is to raise your self-worth.
How do you raise your self-worth?
Check your peer group.
If you upgrade your peer group,
you'll upgrade your
self-worth, case closed.
What do I mean by that?
Well, if you hang around
with 10 drug addicts,
I've got news for you.
The law of conformity says
you'll likely become the 11th.
If you hang around with
10 highly motivated
self-made multimillionaires
that are up and busy,
on purpose, with something, and inspired
to go out and create value,
you're likely become the 11th.
You see, raise your self-esteem,
trade your peer group,
and ask yourself a question.
How can I add value?
And all of a sudden, you look
over your shoulder one day
and think, "Wow, where
did that money come from?"
Because now you're focusing
on what you can give,
which is the by-product
or a consequence of that
is money coming in.
Rather than sitting in front at the fire,
and bitching about the
fact that it's cold,
and if only you had some heat,
you'll go outside and fetch some wood.
That doesn't work.
You want more money?
Become a person of value.
Upgrade your self-worth,
mix with the people
that already have what
it is that you want,
contribute in adding value,
and I guarantee money won't be far behind.
If you are able to understand
that you get to choose the
meaning of what happens,
you get to take responsibility
for your data-processing
of the five senses.
Two men sat behind
prison bars, one saw mud,
the other saw stars.
The condition is identical
in both scenarios.
How one chooses to
interpret that condition
determines whether or
not you go off on a track
towards empowerment, or
whether you go off on a track
that becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
of more stress and resentment
with your current life condition.
If you've ever had a
relationship with somebody,
or an intimate relationships
where, for example,
they left you.
Same scenario, two different
ways of looking at it.
One, you can turn around and say,
"Well, I'm clearly no
good, so they left me."
Or you can say, "Well,
thank God they went,
"so they made room for
somebody who's right.
"Next!"
Now just stay with that
example for a second.
If you suddenly go out and a year later,
six months down the line, whatever it is,
if I were on the first scenario,
"I'm no good, so they left me."
And that's my belief, that's all it is,
has nothing to do with the actual event,
the event is the event.
But if I'm processing my data management
through the filter or the
belief, or the choice of
"I'm no good, so they left me."
Because that's my story,
that's my upbringing,
that's my social conditioning,
that's my parents,
that's my fill-in-the-blank.
We all have a story, my friends.
Then, the next time I go to meet somebody,
or I'm introduced to somebody,
what are my default thoughts?
"Oh, I wonder if this person
thinks I'm good enough."
Now if that's your starting place,
I can predict what's going to
happen over the next two dates,
if you get to number
two, that is. (laughs)
Whereas, if you turn around,
if we rewind six months before,
and you say, "Next!
"Oh, yeah, thank goodness that person went
"so they made room for
somebody who's right."
And that is your default
level of processing,
'cause it's a choice.
Then next time you meet somebody,
what is your default level
of being able to interact?
Well, yeah, I wonder if
this person's going to be
fortunate enough to spend
to spend some time with me.
And as long as it comes
from a place of authenticity
not arrogance, because
you're feeling empowered,
not disempowered, yeah, your second date's
going to be a very different experience.
You understand what I'm saying?
We create our interpretation
of meaning of the world,
irrespective of the
external circumstances.
If I'm going to do business with somebody,
I want to do business with somebody I like
and somebody I trust.
We want to be in business
with those people.
So what does it take to like
somebody and trust somebody?
If you're putting on some
level of fake rapport skills,
because you've learnt some NLP technique
on how to be closely in alignment
with somebody who's visual
versus auditory or kinesthetic,
then that's going to get you in the door.
But there's an inherent
level of falseness with that.
Sincerity comes from a level
of empathy and intention
that is there to express who
you are to serve your client.
If you don't have the
ability to respect your time,
nobody else will.
- Yeah.
- Now it doesn't mean to say
you got to be a jerk about it.
There is something respectful
about people who own their own time.
And if somebody calls me and says,
or goes through my secretary
saying they want a meeting,
nobody gets access to time
with me unless they send
an agenda in advance,
and we assess it as being
mutually beneficial.
- Yeah.
- Otherwise, I'm not
going to be able to focus
on what my mission is, I'm going
to be serving everybody else's
Now, you see, many people avoid that
because they have a fear of rejection.
They don't like saying no.
"I don't want to hurt
somebody's feelings."
- Yeah, this is the main problem.
I cannot just give the
time to someone else.
- But that's not about
them, that's about you
being driven by the good opinion of others
and scared of rejection,
because you think it's a person sop.
But if you own yourself,
and you own your truth,
it's very easy to say no to people.
It's like, I've employed
hundreds of people over the years
in different businesses.
And sometimes you've
got to let go of people.
And I don't see that as ruining their day,
I see that as giving them an opportunity
to be in a job that's
better suited to them.
Now, they may not see that at the time
when they're focusing on scarcity.
- Improve themselves, yeah.
- Or the fact that they
don't have wages next week.
- Yeah.
- But, I don't want them being in a place
where they don't fit.
And if they don't have the
courage to recognize that
and leave it, then I'm the
guy that needs to help.
And three months down the line,
when they hopefully get a better job,
or find themselves in a better position,
and if they look back at the time when
the transition point was there,
they thank me for having the
courage to make that decision
for them if they didn't.
So I don't need the good opinion of others
if I'm walking my truth, and
I'm always coming from a place
of wanting to serve.
It's not an egocentric position.
I'm not trying to say,
"Well, screw you, my time's
"more important than yours."
I'm saying, "Well, right now,
"this doesn't serve our outcome."
It's got to be mutually beneficial.
And if you need some time
and this is a project
you want my advice on, then,
A, I have an hourly rate
that you can book.
But if you're looking for free advice,
I have a huge amount of
information out there on YouTube
that I do so that people
that can't afford my time
can have access to some benefit.
But, other than that, I'm very sorry,
my time and my mission isn't aligned
with where yours is right now.
Now if there's one area that
I see stopping so many people
from living their dream,
from fulfilling the potential
that they were born to
fulfill, it is getting over
the fear of failure.
So how do you do that?
How do you take that fear
and rip it out by the roots
and throw it away so it
never bothers you again?
You start to understand what
fear of failure is actually is,
'cause for many people, all
it is is being sucker punched
by the good opinion of
other people caring about
what they think.
You know how often that keeps up down?
Do you know how much of a life is wasted
caring about what we think
other people are thinking?
And the reality is this.
You start as the number one
A-list actor in your movie
called Your Life.
Do you not?
Which means that everybody else
either is a supporting cast,
or a film extra, in the
movie of your life, correct?
But what does that really mean?
We walk around thinking people look at us
as the star in our movie, but they don't.
Everybody else is living the same dream,
they're walking around in
the star of their own movie,
and we're just a film
extra in their movie.
So if we stop taking the actions
that we think we will
lead towards success,
because we think we're worried
about what the good opinion
of other people will do to us.
I've got news for you,
so listen carefully.
I don't get on my soapbox
about many things,
but I'm getting on it about this, guys.
Nobody cares enough about you
to bother to give an opinion
because they're too busy being
worried about what they think
you're thinking of them.
Failure?
Failure is not taking your step.
Failure is not picking up the
bat and swinging it at life.
Failure is getting to the end of this game
and regretting what we didn't do.
Failure is about saying, "What if."
Failure is lying on
your death bed thinking,
"Oh, well, if I only I
could go back and do"
fill-in-the-blank.
You know something?
To me, failure is not falling down,
it's staying down when you've fallen.
You have to fail by the definition of
"Oh, I didn't succeed."
in order so you can succeed.
That's what life is about.
It's not about taking
it with you at the end,
it's not about score keeping.
I've probably failed
more times than I've won,
but I keep my average
number of tries high.
And do you know what happens?
Guess what?
You tap into a lesson of
history that most people ignore.
And that is this, it's
the paradox of history.
For those that risk the least in life,
usually end up with the least in life.
Just because our brain won't tell us that
when we have to pay
our mortgage on Friday,
doesn't mean it isn't true.
So get up and get in the game.
Who you are right now watching this
is as a result of your
failures, not your successes.
It is when we're tested,
when the storm is ripping
the branches off our tree,
when the rain cloud are there
and we think we've got nothing left.
That's who we are at our best,
when we show up when we're tested.
The strongest trees grow
in the strongest winds,
not in the best soil.
So next time you have an opportunity,
next time you start to question
whether you should step forward or not,
or would it be a white
square on the chess board,
or a dark square or not?
Who cares, get in the game,
swing the bat, be all you can be.
Get up, and if anybody says,
"Oh, you're doing that?"
or "Oh, you did that?
"Oh, look at, you failed."
Know this, they're failing
in their judgement of you,
not in your ability to pick
up the bat and swing it again.
That's the person you were
born to be, my friends.
That's the person who you are.
You were born a miracle,
you are good enough.
You don't need me to tell
you that, you already are.
Get out there, get in the game,
go embrace it, and if you
fall over, pick yourself up,
swing the bat again.
And let's go play this game of life.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
Kevin Lye asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Peter say
that had the biggest impact on you
in your business or your life?
What change you're going to
make after watching this video.
Please leave it in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally want to give a shout
out to Jaslin Purification.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
and making that awesome
Facebook art that you posted.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(exploding boom)
- Determination, for me, is
far more important than desire.
Desire comes from a place
of thinking I need it.
Therefore, the presupposition
is "I'm not good enough,
"because I don't already have it."
Determination is simply a case of
"Well, here's where I'm focused,
here's where I'm going."
I don't need it, I'm
just choosing to get it.
And get out of the damn
way, 'cause I'm moving.
Questions direct our focus.
And if you're not
directing your own focus,
I've got news for you.
There's a lot of people
that pay a lot of good money
to Madison Avenue to figure
out how to do it for you.
- [Evan] Right.
- And that's not the
life you want to live,
being programmed by
other people's agendas.
And I liken the mind to a compass needle.
It can only point in
one direction at a time.
And the challenge is, just
like if we take a needle,
and magnetize it like back in high school.
You take a magnet, a power source,
and you align it, and
keep stroking that needle
in one continuous direction,
'til that needle aligns to
the magnetic field, and becomes coherent,
all of the ions pointing in one direction,
it becomes magnetized.
Our mind is very similar.
If we are open to
unconsciously being programmed,
which unfortunately as
human beings we are.
We're a 24/7 constant adaptation machine,
our mind our body.
Now we understand the
body part, that's easy.
The physical side of life everybody gets,
because they have
experiential evidence of it.
Now your body will adapt if
you put it in McDonald's,
or if you put in the gym, it doesn't mind,
it will adapt accordingly, that's its job.
But our mind is far more
programmable, far quicker
than our body.
And if the magnet, the strong
force that's constantly
magnetizing us, is usually
the media and our peer group.
And if those two aren't
optimal, then we're going to be
sucked along for the ride,
and don't really magnetize
our true north for ourselves.
So by asking better
questions, what it does
it shifts the direction of that needle.
Now the challenge is, you can only do that
for 10% of the time that you're conscious,
or sleeping, awake is how most
people are 90% of the time.
That's why when we're driving to work,
we can't remember the last
two remember kilometers
on the freeway, (laughs) that will happen.
But, now if we focus on
being able to magnetize
or take charge of which direction
that compass needle is pointing,
we have a chance to start
reinventing ourselves.
Because, otherwise, again,
you're going to be drifting,
especially in that 90% of
time where we do things
out of habit, unconsciously,
that compass needle
drifts back to its
pre-conditioned magnetic north.
Now most of the time,
that's doesn't serve us,
whether it's media
condition, people condition,
via society condition.
Looking out of your window,
there's not many examples
who we really want to emulate and become
that surround us on on a day-to-day basis.
There is a way, believe it or not,
that you can actually be luckier,
and it's far simpler than you realize,
especially when you understand
some of the science,
and biochemistry, and neurochemistry,
as to what's really going on.
And when I say lucky,
I'm talking about things
just falling into place, seemingly so,
or if you meet the right person,
or the right deal lands on your plate,
and a lot of this is actually,
you're able to set this
up in a a way where
the odds are more in your favor.
Just like if you're in a casino,
life for some people is
where you put enough quarters
in the machine, and you may
get three cherries in a row,
'cause there's so much going on in life,
so many plates spinning simultaneously,
that occasionally, yes,
you'll just be lucky
and get three cherries
in a row, that happens.
But, more often than not,
how do we stack the odds
in our favor?
Now if you go to the roulette table,
and you're betting black and red,
the house will always win over time.
Why?
Because it's just not 50/50.
There's a loss a little
green option called zero,
which stacks the odds
in the house's favor,
yet a little bit more than 50%.
So the mathematics is the
house will always win.
You may get lucky, but the
house will always win over time.
So how do you go from being a person
spinning the wheel in life,
hoping that it's going
to land on your color,
versus becoming the house,
whereby every single time,
over time, you know ultimately,
things are going to
work out in your favor.
Well, let me share with
you an incredible part
of the human anatomy that
allows that to happen.
It's called the reticular
activating system,
and it's a part of the brain
that has a very specific job to do,
and it's usually misunderstood.
But the reticular activating system
is really the gatekeeper between conscious
and the unconscious mind.
And hit has a sway over what information
it allows in from a sensory input.
Now how do we make the
reticular activating system
work for us, when we want to
be, quote, unquote, lucky.
Well, we need to understand
that it does one job
and one job only, primarily
for the purposes of this video.
And that is it allows
in, to our conscious,
information that falls
under two categories.
One, is information that
can be harmful to us.
And the other is information
that we vote on it
being relevant.
So, for example, let's
talk about the first
type of information,
stuff that can be harmful.
So we're driving along, and
we're somewhat unconscious,
as most people are, in
what I call sleeping awake,
which is why you tend to
drive to work on your day off,
because you've done it so many
times, you're unconscious,
you're moving forward just out of habit.
But we tend to wake up just
as the car in front of us
brakes a little early and snaps us out.
That's because the
reticular activating system
is constantly scanning for
something that could be danger.
And it works in conjunction
with another part of of the
brain called the amygdala,
whose job is to really notice things
that are negative or
dangerous, before positive.
So the amygdala will notice that,
flag it up to the reticular
activating system,
bring it into your conscious awareness,
while everything else, meanwhile,
is swept under the carpet.
And the amygdala's a
fascinating part of the brain.
As I say, if you're walking
past a tree, 10,000 years ago,
and you miss an apple, no big deal.
But if you miss a snake,
it could be a big deal.
So it's always scanning in conjunction
with the reticular activating system,
to see if there's
anything in our awareness
that could be dangerous, harmful,
or threaten us physically.
So, in terms of the other information,
what we tell it is important.
Now here's where we start
getting interesting,
when we talk about getting lucky.
See, the reticular activating system will,
as a faithful servant,
irrespective of the nature
of the import, do its job.
So if you, for example, our name,
we know our name is important to us.
So if we're at a party, and
we're having a conversation
with somebody, and
there's lots of background
conversations going on.
But somebody at the other side of the room
happens to mention our name.
In mid-conversation, we will be pulled out
and look over to see who mentioned
our name across the room,
in the middle of another conversation.
Why is that?
It's because the reticular
activating system
is constantly scanning
all of this information,
and it's deleting, distorting,
and generalizing 99% of it.
I say otherwise we'd be
completely overwhelmed.
And it's sweeping that under
the carpet of our awareness,
our conscious awareness,
and just flagging up what's important.
That's why we didn't hear
somebody else's name,
but we would hear our name.
So if we tell the
reticular activating system
what is important, it
will go and find it in the
millions of bytes and bits of information
a second that's it being processed.
So you could walk down the street
and completely miss an opportunity,
because you haven't told the
reticular activating system,
or your brain, that it
is relevant or important,
even though it's working up millions
of pieces of information every second.
Give you another example.
If you had a six-year-old daughter,
and she turns around and
says, "Daddy, daddy, please,
"I would love a bike for birthday, please,
"that's all I want is a bike."
You know, "Okay, honey."
And you to your wife, "I've got
to get our daughter a bike."
And you're driving to work the next day,
and then all of a sudden
you drive past a bike shop.
And you notice a bike
shop on the way to work.
Now it's been there for
the last five years,
every day you've driven to work.
You noticed it in your
reticular activating system,
but because you haven't told
your brain it was important,
it swept it under the carpet of awareness,
and you didn't notice
it in your conscious.
But now you've said it's relevant,
so it pulls it out of
all of the information.
Says, "Hey, guess what?"
Wow, just the same as if you buy a car
and you start seeing that
car everywhere on the road.
Of course it was there before,
there wasn't a half-price sale on it,
now everybody's bought the same car.
No, you've now told your
reticular activating system
this particular car, make,
model, color, what have you,
is now more relevant to me in my life
and then out of the hundreds
or thousands of cars
on the road, whenever it
spots one, as it always did,
it will flag it up.
Basic neuroscience.
So how do we make that work for us?
Well, if it's going to constantly, 24/7,
look for all of the
information that is out there,
that's beyond our conscious comprehension,
or our ability to process
consciously, and start scanning,
what a great opportunity that is.
See, if I turn around and say,
"Right now I'm looking
for a business partner.
"I'm looking for a store, a
premises, a vacant premises.
"I'm looking for certain
kind of property."
And you say it's relevant,
you're going to start noticing
things like that, while
you're driving along,
in the process of normal conversations,
when you're standing in
a line up at Starbucks,
overhearing somebody talk about a business
that's relevant to you,
because you're telling it its important.